as we sink deeper into the fever dream
that is this unusually divisive and fear
filled season it's nice to have an
antidotal feeling in the form of winter
holidays throughout which despite being
co-opted by Hallmark commercialism a
sense of family and of coming together
predominates my favorite ritual of this
time of year is the annual broadcast of
Frank Capra's It's a Wonderful Life on
Christmas Eve
what was once a post-war box-office flop
has become a cultural phenomenon
recognized as one of the great cinematic
masterpieces by one of our very best
directors watching it of course it's
tempting to brush off this film is
overly sentimental and nostalgic which
it is but I think we judge it like this
at our own peril indeed with It's a
Wonderful Life Capra interrogate some of
the key contradictions at the heart of
American life to see whether or not they
can be reconciled or if in fact they
don't exist at all
contradictions between the individual
and the community between adventure and
domesticity and between success and an
ordinary life he stages these
contradictions in the figure of George
Bailey a citizen of the small town of
Bedford Falls and the president of the
local building and Loan as the film
begins we don't know exactly what has
happened to George only that he's in
serious trouble and has reached the end
of his rope and that he's about to be
aided by divine intervention in the form
of a guardian angel seeking to earn his
wings we learned about George's life as
his angel does in a series of flashbacks
if you're going to help a man you want
to know something about him don't you
George we learn has big dreams of
leaving Bedford Falls traveling the
world and becoming a metropolitan
archetype shake on the dust of this
crummy little town off my feet and I'm
gonna see the world but his selflessness
his drive to do the right thing
repeatedly comes in the way of these
dreams we also learn about Bedford Falls
a close-knit community of mostly good
people leading simple lives which is
under the constant threat of being taken
over by a ruthless businessman called
mr. Potter
the only thing standing in Potter's way
is George Bailey his father and their
empathetic building and Loan
operation the foil to potter the clear
representation of corruption and evil in
the film is not George himself but Mary
hatch George's eventual wife a
compassionate young woman who is quite
happy to stay and live in Bedford Falls
it's important to note that both Potter
and Mary show up in every flashback
representing George's desires for fame
and fortune on the one hand and his
drive to do the right thing for his
community on the other of course its
Mary side that eventually wins out but
for the large majority of the film
George is not rewarded for doing the
right thing he's punished when young
George rescues his brother from a
freezing lake he loses the hearing in
his left ear when he warns his boss
about a potentially disastrous accident
he gets beaten when his father dies he
takes on his responsibilities at the
building and Loan he loses his chance
for travel in college when there's a run
on the bank he misses his own honeymoon
every noble sacrifice for Bedford Falls
makes Bedford Falls feel more like a
trap and instead of bringing him closer
to the community he's helping Capra
shows him isolated from it in this shot
after realizing that his dreams of
travel are finally squashed for good
George stands isolated against a train
that he'll never get on before he walks
slowly back into the crowd putting a
smile on again like he always does
despite this parade of personal wounds
George is able to remain resilient until
the very end when his scatterbrained
uncle miss places $8,000 and puts him in
danger of going to jail for fraud things
get worse and worse and George believing
himself worth more dead than alive
contemplates suicide it's at this point
that his guardian angel
Clarence intervenes
clarence oddbody angel second class
shows George what Bedford Falls would
have been like had he never existed what
George sees is a night Bedford Falls is
now Pottersville and all the dreams he
had of an exciting life of adventure and
exotic ism have returned as perverted
versions of themselves on the main drag
of his former home the moon that George
promised to lasso for Mary that she had
made into a lovely needlepoint picture
is made ugly and sleazy in the form of
the blue moon cafe martinis bar a place
where any break from decent behavior was
not tolerated as become a garish
speakeasy where anything goes everything
is turned into an opportunity for crass
commercialism even George's home has
become a boarding house now when George
finally gets his old life back he's
rewarded with generosity from the
community who bailed him out in an
unbelievably touching finale that ends
with everyone including the cops who
came to arrest him singing auld lang
syne
it's easy to get carried away in this
wave of feeling but it's important to
remember what hasn't changed and that's
basically everything George Bailey still
has to live in his drafty old house
scraping by to support his family his
business despite being bailed out by the
town remains at the brink of being
swallowed by Potter's relentless
expansion and he Potter faces no
consequences at all despite being the
main protagonist despite stealing money
from George Bailey he's not vanquished
he's up $8,000 in some sense Capra
reconciles the contradictions I
mentioned before success is not mutually
exclusive to an ordinary life adventure
can be found in a domestic setting and
yet the most basic contradiction that
between the individual and the community
is left open-ended America has struggled
with this contradiction since before its
founding how does a culture predicated
on individualism maintain public virtue
how does an economic system that
incentivizes individual success keep
from exploiting communities if you have
the answer tell us because we're still
at the eve of 2016 struggling to figure
it out
I feel George's dilemma as I'm sure many
of you do the world shines with the
promise of adventure and possibility all
that could be gained experience learned
if only you were to commit yourself to a
radical individualism and yet the
responsibilities of family and of the
community mag they call us back they ask
us to sacrifice in solution to this
everyone finds their own balance but you
should keep in mind that it's these
personal dilemmas played out in society
at large that ultimately draw the fault
lines in our politics in Frank Capra and
George Bailey's time following World War
two the idea of an American destiny of
the American Way
still had weight and consensus a string
of disasters have weakened our resolve
in such a thing have fractured our
ability to imagine a consensus and into
the void rushes the heirs to Henry
Potter this is why the message of It's a
Wonderful Life a message of hope and
spective is not so shallow as it seems
the contradictions in the film are never
quite resolve something beautifully
dramatized by the finial on George's
stairs there will always be an
incompleteness to life but hope is not
naive its hardiness and resolve against
a situation that cannot give us
assurances or guarantees the film shows
us that a change of heart and
perspective far from being powerless
nostalgia in the face of an unusually
divisive and fear-filled season can be a
genuinely revolutionary attitude
hey everybody thanks for watching and
Happy Holidays whenever you celebrate
out there if you want to help me make
more of these nerdwriter videos if you
like what I'm doing here and you want to
see more I'd ask you to pledge a little
bit of money to my patreon page
everything helps you guys have been so
generous so far and you know all the the
money that you pledge goes directly into
improving this channel you know these
take a lot of time and essentially money
to make so everything you do is much
much much much much appreciated this is
one of my favorite movies of all time
Jimmy Stewart is my favorite actor of
all time someone once said that George
Bailey was like a vessel that Jimmy
Stewart poured every nuance of his being
into and I totally agree with that I
love this movie I'll never get tired of
it i watch it every year thank you again
for watching and I will see you guys
next Wednesday